there are lots of
unwritten rules in esports always teabag
an opponent never bet on the best team
going into ti
never taunts before you get the kill but
the most important one of all is
never pay to win when you can buy a
messed up skin a broken character or
some other awful boost
the competitive integrity of a game goes
out of the window
so let's take a look at the very worst
cases of this
with the top 10 pay to win [ __ ]
i hope you're sitting close to your
screen for our first entry
the shattered web skins
who didn't see me he literally didn't
see me he looked right at me and then he
started to look away
they made ces paid to win i can't
believe it
the shattered web agent skins in cs go
were
kind of [ __ ] they were so hard to
see against
certain surfaces that players were
getting killed by enemies who were
basically
invisible
this game i need to fix it buying the
skin
gave you a huge competitive advantage
which meant the skins were quickly
banned from pro tournaments
and they became something of a meme
within the cs go community
if you can't cry you might as well laugh
maybe a little bit okay clear graveyard
a little bit
there's literally no one here well yes
there is
he looks like a flowerpot
coming in at number nine we have one of
league of legends most
infamous skins i blitzcrank the time of
man has come to an end blitzcrank
hooks people it's kind of his thing it's
not too difficult to dodge
normally but this skin makes it
notoriously hard
ever since its release in 2013 players
have been complaining about
how hard it is to see the hook animation
i mean just
look at this
[Music]
the skin has allegedly been banned from
past tournaments due to this design flaw
and i blitzcrank has been memed on by
those who are exhausted of phantom hooks
it's the result of this approach it's
been
completely redesigned and for the first
time
ever we've increased the size of the
display
at number eight today is fifa's ultimate
team
the team building system that is pay to
win from top to
bottom he's not even good i just [ __ ]
defended that whole play man
and pay to win shits bro the pay-to-win
is crazy this year
fifa ultimate team is the mode used to
build your team
in fifa playing games earns you coins to
get better players
the problem is you can also get these
coins with
fifa points which you guessed it you can
buy
with real money this means real money
can get you
ridiculously strong players
oh my god i'm done out here he's sweaty
as well
ah i'm done i'm done i'm done i'm done
i'm finished i'm finished i'm finished
boys i'm finished
there are similar stories in other ea
franchises but it seems to have reached
new levels for fifa in recent years as a
pro player told the footception podcast
in 2019. the money i've put in fifa
is like in a way a sickening amount when
i think of it
but it's the only way in order to fully
be able to compete
this year on fifa fifa pro tim
schwartman made a stir
in september 2020 when he said he
wouldn't be spending
a penny on fifa points anymore back in
fifa 19
zim another pro said he'd spent almost 5
000 on points to get the players that he
felt
he needed to compete with adding it
shouldn't be like this you should never
have an advantage
just for paying yes they're a big
company that has to make their money i
understand that
but there's a fan base that has been
backing this game for years
that we're just slowly moving away from
each other
and how we feel more more more and more
each day next up at number seven
we have the most deceiving skins you'll
ever see
oh my god okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
look pretty much every fortnight skin
has been accused of letting you pay to
win
at some point but there's one kind of
skin in particular
that's really egregious skins that let
you pose as something you're not
he's trying to buy something from me
[Music]
no way i cannot believe that that just
happened i feel bad now
the breakpoint skin is almost identical
to the hologram in the cantina
so players figured out that if they sync
their emote with it
they become almost undetectable i know
somebody here
john wick
perhaps the most blatant example is the
mystique skin which allows a player to
shapeshift into whoever they
just eliminated which wouldn't be a
problem if it didn't include
npcs always make sure you're talking to
the real snomando
ah you thought i was the nbc
he tried to talk to me he's trying to
talk to me
it's the return of the mac and number
six with warzone's mac 10.
we'll be talking about a gun that's
literally
pay to win in december 2020 call of duty
warzone released a battle pass which
allowed players to get the gallantry
blueprint for their mach
10. the battle pass cost 1300 call of
duty points or a little over 10 dollars
the thing is the mach 10 was nerfed
pretty hard not long before
this and the gallantry blueprint
basically reversed those nerfs
entirely if you were willing to pay up
but hey guys don't fret behold you just
go for armory gallantry
boom swap your attachments out for
whatever you would like to have
and then you have more or less the
absolute
unnerved mac 10 that is just a complete
clapper
the galantry blueprint it's a mac 10
blueprint and this blueprint literally
gives you a better recoil pattern than
the
normal mach 10. it's more accurate it
has a tighter hipfire accuracy
and the damage to the head is actually
more so
essentially you could pay 10 bucks and
wipe away the nerf to the mach 10 that
affected other players
bucks for buffs is never a good trade so
what this means is if you use the
blueprint
even if you're shooting him in the toe
it's like you have a hundred percent
headshot rate
with the regular mach 10. that's why
it's deleting people
the only way devs have tried to get you
to pay to win
sometimes new characters could be so
broken that a couple of dollars are all
you need to
jack up your win rate that's why leroy
smith
is taking the halfway spot on our list
step one
you pick leroy step two you push some
buttons
step three you win leroy had it
all powerful buttons amazing damage and
of course easy combos you have to duck
down and commit the duck until the end
of it
but look at this comeback you're dead
it got so bad that evo japan 2020
seven of the players in top a used leroy
at some point
in the tournament and only three of them
used any other character
at all look at that running it all the
way through
winners with none other than leroy smith
the new
character at it this season oh but
yeah just pick rerun i think
bandai namco eventually nerfed leroy
into being a normal character
but for a few weeks there he really was
just pay to win
moving on to number four we have ember
rise when rainbow six siege released the
mvarai skins in september 2019
ubisoft were hit with complaints that it
made enemies almost
impossible to see against certain
backgrounds
you blend in with walls and you don't
know what operator you're playing
against and it's like every character
pretty much they have 50
like every character people were pulling
their hair out every time they got
picked off by what
looked like a wall even the pros felt
like they couldn't win
unless they bought the skin eat who
gave us the money to buy the skin as a
business expense
because it was necessary to win secure
the bomb they paid us
money to buy the ember eyes
it became a game of spot the enemy with
people having to bust out
red circles just to show where the ember
rise players were lurking
coming in at number three we have
fortnite superhero skins
literally standing by a tree and this
guy isn't literally not noticed i still
don't think that i still don't think he
knows
this is pay to win when marvel partnered
with epic games to release their
superhero skins into fortnite it quickly
became apparent that they weren't just
super in name
they were broken the brand new superhero
skin
you can not only make it solid green
you can make it solid any damn color you
want
and this didn't just affect your average
game of fortnite either
even the pros felt like they needed it
to compete
now we have the superhero skins and a
lot of pro players are rocking the
all-black superhero skins like
black mask top and bottom that way they
can camouflage and be harder to spot
epic games eventually issued a refund
and made it so that you could never
choose just
a single color for the skin but hey
it was fun while it lasted of course we
didn't get circle again
oh that's good that's that's that's
that's a great hiding spot
our runner-up today is project ash and
her insane ult
but we have to see the pick itself blank
burned his ghost early and then faker
runs up away from the make it rain and
equalizer
as he's just getting drilled by the ash
arrow
ash is one of the simplest characters to
pick up in league but her project ashken
has been giving people a headache ever
since its release
the hitbox on her ult is broken you
might think the arrow is going to fly
right by you and then nope you somehow
get hit in the face and stunned
her ultimate her arrow is a little bit
harder to see but it's also a lot
smaller than the actual hitbox of the
ability
so it's really misleading and can be
difficult to dodge
oh close over there oh wait wait i don't
help i don't have brand news
did you see that it's kind of [ __ ]
and it's been happening for
years at this point you've heard of
something flying as straight as an arrow
well i don't think they meant this one
what no way dude that hitbox
what the [ __ ] and finally
taking the number one spot on today's
list is the single most broken character
in pay to win history
bayonetta but one flip up from jj and
over extension and uh backers gonna do
it
oh no now this probably isn't the stock
but it's going to be a ton of
oh my wow smash 4's life was dominated
by
two dlc characters cloud and bayonetta
for a long time people joked that cloud
was so powerful
and easy to use that you could just pay
a few bucks and win your local
tournament
for free and then bayonetta happened
off to an amazing start here oh
take that he said oh no take that email
did you guys see that with the ability
to kill any character from
anywhere on stage from almost any hit
bayonetta was
a nightmare to play against jesus jesus
did you see how high he popped up what
the
dog she was so powerful that some people
even considered
banning her you were simply never safe
when your opponent was using bayonetta
which meant that your only real option
was to drop the 599 and learn the combos
to beat the
other bayonetta players
salem just painted the side of the stage
with a cloud
across the stage and the worst part
after two sets of extremely minor nerfs
to bayonetta the year she came out
smash 4 was never patched again meaning
the six bucks can still carry you to
tournament victories to this day
all right then which one of those was
the worst offender
have you ever paid to win in a game
don't worry i'm not judging do you know
what is free though
subscribing to the score esports youtube
channel if you haven't done so already
thanks for watching guys and i'll see
you all in the next one
handle it